what's it been like to you
watching this play out on social media
like i've seen a lot of misinformation
i've seen videos like look how awesome
this video is it's from 2014. the
associate npr had a thread maybe i'll
try and find and share it was like
here's all the things that have been
going viral that are completely false i
just think what if you see disastrous
for our mental health that we're
watching a war play on social media a
real a real like large-scale war yeah
and
i think for young people in particular
like it really shakes your foundation
because you think to yourself hey i live
in a city um oh look i'm seeing these
people like fleeing for their lives i'm
seeing apartment buildings getting
shelled i'm seeing
uh
people making their own tanks just roll
into town i'm seeing civilians russia
surround the capital city whoever it is
yeah yeah yeah it's like i think it's
just terrible for everyone's
mental health and well-being on a level
that i can't recall
um
you know like i'm imagining i'm
remembering when folks were watching tv
in the 90s during the gulf war in gulf
war 2. social media was not to this
level and you didn't have folks just
broadcasting what was going on in those
locations
like world war ii right was the first i
mean maybe you could argue you could
argue
but world war ii that fundamental evil
you know i'm saying yeah yeah and but it
was still distant you're reading about
it via newspapers right here you're what
you're witnessing you're [ __ ] living
that evil right yes uh i'm on social
media and one of the things i don't do
is i don't
amplify
um these videos that make you feel very
intensely
uh one thing or another you know like
999 times out of a thousand i'm like i'm
not going to
amplify this yeah because
uh you know it just makes you feel
um
[Music]
very very strongly one emotion whether
it's horror or
anger or fear or fear anxiety or even
some of the positives where it's like
look at this there's some beautiful
stories
like look at this moral actor look at
this like like you know like i'm so this
is something that i you know it's kind
of tough for me to say but i feel like
even the positive stuff like it it's
kind of
um
like reinforcing
uh a
reactivity that i don't think is very
positive or healthy
where it's like pretty much if you home
in on this beacon of
um like horrific or uplifting behavior
um then you get whipsawed in various
ways like like if if i'm magnifying
something like super
um courageous and uplifting then i feel
like that person's then just gonna go
from there to another video that's
horrifying and then just wound up you
know having their uh emotional pendulum
just like swing back ukraine algorithm
yeah yeah and and so it's it's not
productive or healthy i mean like a lot
of the way i live is to think okay what
can i do about this i don't know how
often we talk about the podcast but
between us we talk a lot about
performative empathy it's one thing we
struggle with as
let's call former democrats or folks
with a conscience and empathy where it's
like there are things i can say that'll
make you feel good and make me feel good
and make me feel like i'm on the right
team or doing the right like you know
the things that are just or moral right
but then there's stuff that needs to be
done which is more gritty and
nitty-gritty but like it's it's like
it's solving the root causes of of
police brutality and what we all went
through with george floyd like
you could say the right things you put
the black lives matter flag up you can
do all the things but then if you
actually want to solve that problem it's
complicated it's nuanced that and so in
this situation you have a bunch of
people be like stand with ukraine here's
a wholesome video donate to save the
children or xyz but at the end of the
day there's very little we can actually
do because unless you're going to pick
up a gun get ukraine and fight
or unless you're a government official
that can control money resources food
xyz and russia as well there's there's
nothing you can
the money's not really helping as much
as we we hope i'm sure it's like on the
margins sure but it's not a money issue
realistically um do you agree with that
like the performance maybe it's you
think it's waking people up on
putting the ukraine flagging your
twitter bio isn't really particularly
helping anything or well i think sending
money is always helpful i mean money's
real uh it's real humanitarian things um
you know the the uh expressing
solidarian alignment um you know like
um uh in this instance probably you know
mildly i guess better than nothing i
guess like yeah
you know you do want to distinguish
though between
expression and action uh as uh you've
all have been
put put
and so
uh on this one there really is one human
being at the center of it all and his
name is one [ __ ] guy has vladimir
putin and
you know like if
there's a way that you could somehow
influence what's going on in that state
of mind than you know
um for it other than that try and help
people at the margins now but i i do
think that
that there's something
really really
uh
damaging about folks having
these
real life
uh
conflicts and images playing out in
social media in the way that they are
and
you know unfortunately i think this is
going to be a pattern where one of the
things i put in the war on normal people
is that if you had a trucker convoy was
my example and then you had conflict
break around uh break out around that
trucker convoy then you'd have these
images uh
go out to millions and millions of
people
of some isolated atrocity
and then it would end up inflaming folks
in a particular way
and that's accurate
you know
so
let's say that the ukraine conflict goes
on for
um months which i guess is at least
conceivable
uh you know like now there's going to be
recurring issue as conflicts happen as
uh tragedies happen
uh you know it's something that i think
is terrible for the next generation's
mental health truly yeah
i'm grateful i came of age in the time
before social media
so i
have now written a book and it's coming
out soon we'll talk about it a different
time but on the attention economy in our
like how that's changing everything and
there's just so many things that
dominate our discourse for a hot moment
and then it's as if they never happened
right um and you if you look back at
your year or the past month or six
months like holy cow i was so pissed
about that and then it's just out of out
of sight out of mind it's like we just
go go go to different topics and
this one
i imagine because it's not
at home to us it's not hitting home to
me what's gonna happen is it'll stop
raiding well on tv and we'll move on to
something else the next trucker convoy
and i think that that convoy is actually
moving through texas the one that was in
canada i think uh
the election will happen biden doing
something got the state of the union uh
that just happened that we haven't heard
it yet but it's uh we're recording this
on tuesday but um which is it's the
night for us um
do you think we lose
i guess maybe you're saying no one knows
but we probably start to lose attention
on this and that um
i i think your current ukraine remains
front center while the conflict is
ongoing and i do think that
uh god willing it gets resolved in a
matter of days or weeks and not months
what does resolution look like putin is
like you said before putin declares a
[ __ ] victory
the best case scenario is putin declares
victory and goes back and says hey we
got we made it safe for the separatist
areas of of ukraine
problem solved uh you know like uh
business as usual
that's our best case scenario and worst
is nuclear war right
the worst case is nuclear
conflicts terrifying everybody though i
will say it would be entirely irrational
for his argument to be russian ukraine
our one people we are the same
and i'm going to nuke i'm not a nuke
like that makes zero sense
uh you know one of the things i found
encouraging is that
russians are standing up the russian
people don't like this there's a very
unpopular war
everywhere including russia
yeah last i saw they'd arrested um you
know several thousand people for
protesting so imagine you live under an
authoritarian regime
your
leader is a former kgb strong man
and you decide to protest the war i mean
you pretty much know you're gonna
get arrested and go to jail this is not
like a you know right to assemble
situation no it's not um and so you have
thousands of people willing to risk
themselves that way
um which means in my mind you have
millions of people who feel the same way
there are a number of prominent figures
in russian society who are like hey this
is this war is not nothing that any of
us wants um it really is one malignant
person
leading
uh them to a war that most people
thought was well out of the bounds of
possibility i was just reading that the
u.s was going around to folks being like
hey fyi we think that russia may invade
ukraine and everyone didn't believe it
we're only eight months away from the
midterms what do you think the political
consequences are here
in the united states democrats
republicans i have some thoughts too i
have some funny should share but i want
yours at first
i think that this is
uh
an opportunity for biden to refocus his
presidency on leadership and competence
and morality
and
it sharpens the contrast between him and
the republicans in various ways now most
republicans
are anti-putin supportive of uh these
measures
uh there are some marginal voices that
aren't but you know like that they're
pretty much out there
um so it's not like there's a sharp
contrast whereby it wants to do one
thing republicans want to do something
else yep um but i i think that
this conflict and biden's leadership
uh probably at least mildly maybe
significantly helpful
um for his administration and democrats
so there's a poll that was circled
around a lot was that
most people
um
both democrats and republicans believe
that this situation in russia would not
have happened if trump was president and
that putin was
essentially implying which i think was
like maybe some people believe this that
putin's less scared than buying then he
would be of trump
in doing this
felt that there was
less consequences if he acted i
think if biden
i don't know if i know trump just voiced
approval for this entire course of
action so he does yes but like it
wouldn't have happened
it might have been
the reverse where putin's like hey
trump's going to be cool with this so
let me do this thing and then trump as
president is like hey
uh let russia do russia
perhaps like i'm not disagreeing i'm not
even trying to speculate what trump
would be doing it was just that polls
like
would this have happened if trump was
president so as you tell i'm of the mind
that this totally happens oh yeah i
think it would too i don't think that's
an accurate but i think the this is like
the sentiment and that's the message
that
fox news and the republican party has
been going with like our weak
president and country and lack of
strategy and strength at home is hurting
us abroad and putin thinks he can do
whatever we want without any
consequences right and that is changing
and i do think this could change a tide
i think if biden wants to win in 2024 or
the dems want to win they have we have
to have a
obvious victory here we have to put
putin in his place i'm not sure how to
do that and
people
far smarter than i am hopefully working
on this but i think that's the case the
other thing is the saying is dems suck
at war like i generally don't think
we're great at this um and i don't
like and like it's mainly because you
have
twitter savvy
dems saying dumb stuff and i have one my
favorite one of the dumb things i've
heard i mean by the way twitter is ripe
for hot takes right now if you want to
see ridiculous takes this is a good time
for twitter but eric swalwell who i like
we like we're kind of fun with him on
the trail
he floated the idea and i like when
people float ideas out there we float
ideas up but he floated the idea of
kicking
russian
russians in the u.s out of our
universities in retaliation to putin
invading ukraine yeah that's insane
which is and it's that kind of stuff
that like what do republicans do they
grab it they clip it they play it over
and over and dems are more likely to say
that
as the party is supposed to be rational
republicans are always doing dumb [ __ ] i
mean russians themselves aren't for this
war russian americans i'm sure are
against this war um
my my favorite eric swalwall story was
when we were backstage your first debate
and you show up in the line like we're
all back there and you show up and you
weren't wearing a tie and he was like oh
you're not wearing a tie damn man i was
gonna do that ah and he like he was like
legit jealous and like kind of pissed
himself i was like hell yeah
uh that's my favorite favorite swallow
stuff eric's a good dude and i like eric
yeah yeah but you know and let me be the
first to say that you know uh bad
twitter take does not a human make so no
it was yeah that's fair but i mean aware
of that but this was on camera
he said it but but i'm sure that um
so your earlier point about like i i
made a comment a couple of
podcasts ago about how dems i think feel
pressured to be muscular uh about
war because they feel like it's a weak
spot you feel like republicans that was
my point have the hawkish thing and some
democrats
um get painted as doves they feel like
they need to overcompensate someone
interesting um the most famous example
being hillary's vote to authorize the
iraq war and then later be like oh wow
and then obama was like yeah that was a
terrible decision yeah
uh
so uh on this one
um
biden
seems relatively
balanced uh you know there is like the
hawkish element what you described is
like look who should be they're fighting
there's a significant amount of me it's
like look like this is the most uh
corrupt unjustified uh like
uh evil
instigation of war against democracy
that i can remember uh and so
if there's anything that you'd be
fighting for like this would be
it
um
are democrats generally
painted into a corner that like biden
was
meant to restore a degree of competent
leadership and and i would say that that
is the
projection where it seems like he's in
sync with the european leaders that
they're acting
uh with the united front uh that the the
us has been
competent in this
uh yeah i think it helps them
um and i i feel like
like this portrait is vastly superior to
a trump-led portrait
in another world
[Music]